miss harry économistes et essayiste
auteur de l'ouvragé l'algérie histoire
secrète d'un naufrage annoncé aux
éditions l'harmattan
bonjour camille sari merci de répondre à
nos questions quelle réaction des
algériens ce matin suite au décès
d'abdelaziz bouteflika tristesse ou
indifférence
plutôt indifférence totale parce que el
abas bouteflika était tourné depuis
cent des mauges âge ses eaux puis dire
par l'armée et personne ne s'attend à ce
qu'il y ait des réactions
de soutien ou de contestation parce que
de toute façon
l'ère bouteflika et a été achevée par
l'armée il faut le dire aussi
hélas le moment il peut-être de faire le
dimanche un bilan honnête et sans
ambiguïté sur ses deux décennies
marquées par la la production par les
cultures nommant de fonds par une
dépense de 1000 milliards e
doc de dollars en quinze ans et
mais aussi ses les deux mandat de
bouteflika fall et les quatre mandat de
bouteflika sont si marquée par une
ambulance financière qui est dû aux
marchés internationaux
donc il n'ya regret ou les économistes
et aussi pour le peuple algérien c'est
que cette manne pétrolière et gazière
n'a pas servi au développement à une
industrie fort à un ample à l'emploi et
puis à l'amélioration des conditions de
vie des algériens et des algériennes
les réseaux sont multiples les exposer
dans mon image mais à à l'actif aussi de
monsieur bouteflika sait que il a essayé
de résister et la pression de l'armée il
a essayé de protéger la fonction
présidentielle et de sanctuary zay ses
prérogatives on se rappelle de sa phrase
je ne serai pas président aux trois
quarts je serai président de pleins
pouvoirs mais les incidents de santé
soit cette
hémorragie cérébrale ou ensuite sa
maladie prolongé en fait que le
président bouteflika n'a pas eu le temps
peut-être d'achever cette cette
séparation entre le pouvoir militaire et
louvoie présidentielle civile vous
parlez de qui méritait pas de réaction
de la part de l'armée pas de la réaction
de la part des autorités algériennes
comme à ben majid tebboune à l'actuel
président pas de réaction non plus à
l'international
qu'est-ce que ça traduit ce qu'il va y
avoir quand même des réactions selon
nous est pas du tout
non y aura pas beaucoup de réactions
mais parce que le riz jbe les il est
partagé il est aussi
franchement
plus que favorables à l'éviction de
bouteflika dieu je veux souligner une
chose c'est que le irak il a ses racines
et ses et et ses causes dans la
situation et que socio économique du
pays incontestablement mais si l'armée
n'avait pas donné le feu vert avec les
services de renseignement pour que les
manifestants les manifestants à proche
du palais présidentiel à el mouradia le
irak n'aurait pas pu
aboutir à au départ de teknika autrement
dit le départ de bouteflika c'est un
peuple mécontent frustré qui se
révoltent à juste titre mais aussi la
volonté de la b2 de l'évincer parce
qu'il a mis à la retraite plusieurs
généraux il est là il a hélas usées au
moins
forcer le départ de tous les généraux
qui pouvait le gêner et il voulait
s'arroger tous les pouvoirs mais et que
dire à quel avenir pour le mouvement du
irak est donc à l'origine de la chute
des nazis ce putsch a fait cas quel
avenir que généralement pour pour
l'algérie avec maintenant abdellah j de
t bone quel bilan ce que vous faites du
successeur de l'asis bouteflika
franchement j'aurais aimé tenir d'autres
chorales mais malheureusement
le sait le pessimisme qui le pessimisme
et même une certaine résignation dos de
notre pas en tant qu'expert économique
c'est qu'avec tout ce qu on a donc
essayé de 2-2-2 développés qu'aux idées
de développement
industriel de
diversification de l'économie on est
toujours au point mort et la situation
s'aggrave la population augmente et on
est dans une sorte d'impasse
merci khamis heures les petits problèmes
d'affichage on va on va remettre en
place merci beaucoup camille sari
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tous les
cas on l'a bien compris selon vos propos
abdelaziz bouteflika laisse derrière lui
une image donc d'un président contesté
jean pelle komisarek vous êtes
l'économiste et essayiste auteur de
l'ouvragé l'algérie histoire secrète
d'un naufrage annoncé aux éditions
l'harmattan